want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get inspired by
some of the biggest mistakes from
alibaba founder
jack ma
the future has no experts
right we entrepreneurs
someday we are the experts
right so this is what i think and
when you
when you're entrepreneur get used to
failure today say alibaba you succeed
well our company won't last 102 years
why 102 years because every
target every goal we give to our team
should be very accurate
we were born in 1999 last century we had
one year we want to spend 100 years and
plus one year one or two
across three centuries so very accurate
we never see we are successful because
we are only 19 years old there is 83
years to go
so we will never see we're successful we
just survived
19 years we are lucky but
in the past 19 years we have made
thousands of mistakes
as entrepreneurs don't learn from other
people how they succeed
learn from how these people fail
because a lot of mba schools they teach
you success
successful case studies when you read
too many successful you
think you can be successful no
there are a lot of things that you don't
know
because you know some business school
came to alibaba write
case studies they say i know this is
alibaba
and as you know this is not alibaba they
wanted me to sign after one
week study they say this is case study
alibaba ace
no this is not me they say jack you
don't know you
and that's all right i sighed and
next to five years every year there is a
case study
in qinghua university i was invited
sitting at the back listen to the mba
schools
talk learning about our case study and
they always put a competitor
competitor in alibaba who will succeed
for five years
all they always agree alibaba will die
the competitor will win
but five years all the competitors died
so how can you learn from the case study
like that
learn from the mistakes because the
mistake most of the companies i
i talk to entrepreneurs most of the
mistakes they made are the same
most of the success reasons you don't
know the different reasons
so when you learn from the mistakes not
because you want to avoid mistakes
because
when you see the mistakes when you have
these kind of problems
you know how to face it an entrepreneur
have a strong heart towards
the difficulties mistakes the troubles
the failures
but should it be a warm and soft heart
to your colleagues
and to the customers you tried to get
into three
colleges each time they rejected you
no i i tried there's a examination that
young people if you want to go
university of the taste take the
examinations so i filled it three times
but a lot of failure i feel for funny
things that i failed a key
primary school test for two times and i
failed uh
um like three times for the middle
school good middle schools
and uh you would never believe in
in hangzhou mai city there's only one
middle school
that last only one year it was changed
from
primary school middle school because our
graduates of our
our our school no universe you no middle
school accept us because we were too bad
it would become a middle school
what effect did it have though uh being
rejected
well i think we have to get used to it
we're not that good
even today we still have a lot of people
reject us
i think um when i
uh in the graduate from universities
and before i you know for three years i
tried to fill in the universities
so i applied jobs for 30 times
got rejected i went for a police they
said no you're not good
i went to either even the kfc when kfc
came to china come to my city
20 24 people went for the job
23 people accepted i was the only one
guy
and we went for police five people four
of them accepted i was the only guy that
i received received it
so to me being turned down rejected
oh by the way i told you that i would i
applied for harvard
for 10 times rejected i know if you're
rejected
sorry now ten times you wrote them and
said
i'd like to come to harvard yeah and
then i told myself somebody i should go
teach there baby
what was my biggest mistake
you wanna hear honestly my big biggest
mistake
was i made alibaba
i never thought this thing is
this thing changed my life
[Music]
i was just like trying to do a small
business and grow that
big take that much responsibility and
got so much trouble
every day is like as busy as like a
president
and i don't have any power and then i
don't have my life
so i said in my next life if i still can
have
next life i will never do a business
like this
i want to be on my own self i want to
enjoy my life
if you want even more jack ma motivation
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i did not have a rich father
not from you know well-educated i said i
tried
three times for university all failed